our country is in the midst of a great
national trial unlike any we have ever
faced before you all see it you see it
probably better than most word war with
a deadly virus success in this fight
will require the full absolute measure
of our collective strength love and
devotion very important each of us has
the power through our own choices and
actions to save American lives and
rescue the most vulnerable among us
that's why we really have to do what we
all know is right every citizen is being
called upon to make sacrifices every
business is being asked to fulfill its
patriotic duty every community is making
fundamental changes to how we live work
and interact each and every day and I
wouldn't be surprised to see this going
on long into the future when this virus
is gone and defeated some of the things
we're doing now will be very good
practice for the future including for
not getting the flu which is very
devastating also so some of what we're
learning now will live on into the
future I really believe that shaking
hands or not shaking hands washing hands
all the time staying a little apart 15
days ago we published our nationwide
guidelines to slow the spread of the
virus on Sunday I announced that this
campaign will be extended until April
30th in a few moments dr. Burks will
explain the data that formed the basis
for our decision to extend the
guidelines and dr. Fauci will explain
why it's absolutely critical for the
American people to follow the guidelines
for the next 30 days it's a matter of
life and death
frankly it's a matter of life and death
I know our citizens will rise to the
occasion and they already have
sacrificed a lot we had the greatest
economy in the history of our country
we're the greatest economy in the world
we had the best unemployment numbers and
employment numbers that we've ever had
by far and in one instant we said we
have no choice but to support it just as
Americans have always done they will do
a job like few have seen before
and they're proud to do it I see that
there's a great pride going on right to
him before we hear from our experts we
have a few other announcement today the
Treasury Department and Small Business
Administration announced further details
on the Paycheck protection program which
was made possible by the two trillion
dollar relief bill I signed into law
last week nearly three hundred and fifty
billion dollars in loans will soon be
available through lending partners to
help small businesses meet payroll and
other expenses for up to two months
these loans will be forgiven as long as
businesses keep paying their workers
this includes sole proprietors and
independent contractors applications
will be accepted starting this Friday
April 3rd so on Friday April 3rd that's
what it begins earlier today I spoke
with leading Internet and phone
providers who are doing a tremendous job
of keeping our internet and lines of
communication flowing under very
strongly increased strain the businesses
more than anybody seen before because
everyone's inside they were all making
calls among the leaders I spoke to or
pons
vesper gov her eyes and communications
Randall Stephenson of AT&T Mike sievert
of t-mobile Thomas Rutledge of Charter
Communications Bryan Roberts of Comcast
John Malone of Liberty media
Dexter GUI
of all t's Michael combs of Sprint and
Araya Birkhoff of Lyon tree also Pat
Esser of Cox Communications and Geoffrey
story of CenturyLink they're doing an
incredible job if you look at other
continents if you look at Europe they
want a different route than we did and
much different route we were talking
about that just a little while ago and
they're having tremendous problems other
countries are having problems other
continents are having problems